I will not be worshipped I am NOT your
anointed I don't belong to you dude
you've up you rewind time fix it boom
drop the mic climb the pipe to the Train
oh you'll go is saying what what that's
a rap song I wrote the really only goal
that I've had in my life was to be a
video game voice actor I decided when I
was like 12 that that's what I wanted to
do everything since then has just been
sort of a surprising place Ashley rich
I'm an actor and a voice-over artist for
video games and a writer I'm probably
best known for tiny Tina and Borland's -
Chloe price and life is strange I felt
abandoned a Loy and horizon zero dawn so
much for running from mistakes and
Parvati in the outer worlds let's just
do it proper I first knew that I wanted
to be an actor my second playthrough of
Metal Gear Solid whenever they
introduced a new character - names come
up the character name and then
underneath it was another name so I
looked it up and I was like oh that's
the guy to play Solid Snake that was a
moment that I realized it was a job and
I really wanted to have that job my
brother Anthony and I had a web series
called hey ash whatcha playing which was
like sketch video game comedy from there
Anthony got hired to write at gearbox
for Borderlands 2 as he was writing some
new characters he realized that he had
basically written tiny Tina in my voice
and so I auditioned and I got cast and
that was my very first role which is
pretty wild she was honestly based on my
character in the webseries that my
brother and I did and our friend
Christina from high school all around
the stag just plant the stalker chased
the Bandit the stalker thought twas all
and fun
and it voice-acting for games you kind
of have to be able to think on your feet
pretty quickly without any preparation
and role-playing games you basically
have to be able to perform all of these
different dialogue options as if they
could occur at any point in the game it
all has to flow between whatever choices
the player makes you also have to scream
way more in video games you're usually
gonna have what's called an efforts
session punches kicks pain sounds
horizon zero dawn is an open-world RPG
style game and I play the lead a boy
horizon is actually one of the
best-selling ps4 games of all time
pretty good
careful there you'll sprain your neck
one of the really unique things about
Horizon is that a law is your only
choice so if you don't like her sorry
because she's all yet I'm past trusting
you with secrets I was so nervous
recording horizon zero dawn because it
was rare at the time to only have one
option of who you were playing as and
for that option to be a woman I don't
believe in demons and I don't run when
lives are at stake get out of here
halo is an exceptional fighter and she's
very smart but I wanted her to feel that
there was vulnerability there that there
was some weakness but also balancing
that with compassion and drive and a
focus on what's right I think the thing
that's really started to change in the
industry is that you are getting this
massive influx of really interesting
female characters a lot of the
characters that I've played in games
they're big swings for games I really
think I've been so lucky to be able to
play the characters that I've played
that are so like complex and interesting
[Music]
you